découvre que ce n'est pas c'est plus
qu'une compétition sportive au niveau
sportif c'est une performance
mais c'est beaucoup plus qu'une
compétition sportive c'est une relation
avec un pays
c'est le coeur un peu de la martinique
qui bougent aujourd'hui et cet
impressionnant de vie cela et je suis
très fier de nos équipes qui partagent
pas ce cas la compétition que l'on voit
ici on voit ici des autour de nous il ya
la compétition qui est partagé cet
événement qui est partagé sur les
réseaux sociaux à la radio à la
télévision et ses nombreux
comment dire cette mission de commandes
de médiation qui est importante mais ça
c'est juste nuit sans simple du service
mais je crois qu on le fait avec france